lebanon's three months old
anti-establishment movement seems to be
gradually shifting outbursts of violence
in the streets of the capital Beirut are
becoming more frequent
there have been confrontations between
security forces and stone-throwing
protesters who describes their action as
the beginning of a battle in a Long War
the only way to topple this government
is through riots and violence some
people still believe in peaceful protest
but we have tried that for ninety seven
days a new government was formed this
week but its ministers have been chosen
by the established parties blamed for
widespread corruption they are
struggling for legitimacy at home and
abroad
Muhammad Ali there were conditions
placed by the international community
the US Secretary of State the French
president and the UN Secretary General
all placed conditions for aid they said
they will deal with the government if it
meets the demands of the people and if
it complies with international
resolutions 15:59
and 1701 Lebanon's Finance Minister has
a resna who is already seeking up to
five billion dollars to buy wheat fuel
and medicine acknowledged that foreign
donors were waiting to see the
government's program and the reforms it
would enact Lebanon is facing an
unprecedented crisis and the
responsibility facing the government and
the Finance Ministry is immense Lebanese
protesters aren't the only ones
questioning the ability of the new
ministers to investigate corruption
allegations against the politicians who
appointed them among those politicians
outgoing foreign minister Gibran Basile
who attended the World Economic Forum in
Davos in a personal capacity how did you
get here how did I get to you did you
take a private plane I came simply on my
own expenses on your own expenses so
this is family money no this was offered
to me you know like to have friends like
I was you know I was invited without
implants like that
you think no we're not either
unfortunately if you believe a
government controlled by the Iranian
backed Hezbollah and its allies would be
able to rally support needed to avoid
economic collapse so far there has been
no offer of aid nor a statement of
support from a foreign country for
Hassan Deb's government the US Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo made clear that
international assistance will be
unblocked when the new government meets
the demands of the Lebanese people to
carry out reforms and fight corruption
reforms mean politicians who benefited
from the system will no longer be able
to distribute income and services to
their supporters in many ways that means
giving up power something they seem
completely opposed to doing zina hodor
al Jazeera Beirut